there is something less light-hearted
and more serious that has happened
recently
i was trying to find of late a little
like down time before we get on
i guess we're going straight into it
let's just go straight into depression
so how can we say this boys
one of them one of the greatest mongers
one of my [ __ ] heroes
one of the one of the greatest manga
artists of all time just passed away
recently and it's kind of old news by
the time this game yeah by the time this
comes out this would be like a month old
news now
um but yeah kentaro miura author of
berserk has passed away
and uh age 54 right yeah age 54 of like
what
what did he die of i forgot the
scientific name of it but it's like one
of his like main arteries in his heart
just like
exploded [ __ ] essentially so basically
it's a heart attack
yeah yeah but yeah it's a [ __ ]
horrible way to die i'll tell you
honestly after hearing about this news
i'm never gonna make fun of a hiatus
ever again yeah honestly
not like legit like it's scary man like
because
yeah because you know obviously no one
really knew as to
why he was on hiatus right yeah no one
knew they they normally don't usually
give
reasons they're just like he's on he
she's people are extremely personal yeah
she's on hiatus just deal with it kind
of yeah um
but yeah apparently i guess i don't know
was he sick at all
or was it just completely sudden i don't
really i don't know
at the time recording i haven't read
enough about what happened to know if it
was like a reoccurring health problem or
if it was just a sudden thing but man
like like we all know how much pressure
manga artists get put through
anyway um and how much work they have to
do on a weekly basis
right um i mean it's it's crazy to think
that most of the big
manga artists we know about you know you
know working showing and jump or
whatever
get like two weeks off no less than two
weeks off for a year right
it's like golden week and then like one
extra week yeah
it's just one week that where they are
forced to take a break right i mean i i
wasn't
too familiar with berserk i'd only
watched the uh the 90s anime
i mean that's familiar enough which i
really enjoyed yeah it's great
um but [ __ ] i mean it's just kind of sad
hearing like a legend of the industry
who's kind of influenced a lot of things
that we've done
yeah because i remember we were filming
another project
when the news broke to us yeah didn't
hit me immediately because i was in like
work mode i was filming most obviously i
was like okay gotta do this this this
and then i got home
listened to guts's theme once and he
just played continuously for like the
entire night and i'm just i'm just
sitting there just like [ __ ]
like my soul part of my soul had died
yeah i literally went home and i was
like i'm gonna reread berserk and then
yeah i feel like everyone did
yeah i started reading it yeah i
couldn't get past volume one
without feeling like this [ __ ] wave
of like
[ __ ] yeah cause cause like i i always
know
that berserk is one of the greatest
manga that has ever been made
and then going back home and realizing
just remembering
everything that was in the story and in
this manga
it just hit even [ __ ] harder because
i just had forgotten
how good it was before i really took the
time to remember
what it had achieved and some of its
greatest moments um
if you hadn't read berserk there's
always a there's always
a perfect time to read berserk because
any time is the perfect time to read
berserk so
please read [ __ ] berserk it's amazing
i mean the manga single-handedly
inspired the dark souls series i mean it
despite a lot it wasn't just dark souls
yeah a lot of things wouldn't exist
right now if not for berserk oh yeah
and i don't know what i don't know what
it is about berserk but it's literally
like
it's literally the one show or not not
even one shirt the one
story or the one manga that seems to be
like no matter how
tough this person is no matter how like
detached they are from the world or
whatever berserk seems to be that one
story that seems to be able to
affect anyone who reads it yeah because
like fundamentally
you know it's like this whole like dark
fantasy thing with these like mythical
creatures and it's bloody gory and
you know epic but like the main
themes mostly are just like you know one
person trying to figure out what the
[ __ ] they want to do in life yeah and
like that's a theme that literally
anyone can get behind right like
i'm kind of in this world shit's
happening around me
i don't really know what my purpose is
in life yeah i forgot how brutal it was
it's bro i've walked again i watched all
the other 90s anime yeah holy [ __ ] the
90s obvious brutal as [ __ ]
yeah he was like what the [ __ ] i was
like oh my god like it's just like
[ __ ] it just it just hurts to read
yeah it does it's so uncomfortable at
times yeah and i think it's incredible
because
it is really really [ __ ] brutal there
are some like
like his art obviously we haven't talked
about his audio it's like some of the
best art to ever exist
in the world of manga like some of the
horrific imagery he was managed to
conjure up
and some of like the creature designs
and everything were just
something straight out of a nightmare
you know oh yeah and it was a brutal
show
and it's an action-packed show as well
for his guts is like one of the biggest
badasses
in anime and manga and yet having said
all that
the moments that people remember are
like the really intimate
moments which is which isn't what you
think if you looked at berserk on a
surface level right you look at berserk
you see
these horrific creatures you see guts
with a massive sword tearing [ __ ] up and
you're like
yeah this is a manly man's show and then
you read it and you're just like
[ __ ] crying inside because you know
you see he's
trying to see guts like get through his
trauma and find his
journey and everything like that it's
like it's the real intimate moments that
always
stand out and it's the real serene
moments that always stand out and i
think that's what
that's what really sets berserk apart
from like so many other series where
it's the serene moments juxtaposed
against all like the horrific moments
that make it one of to me like it's one
of my the favor
one of my favorite pieces of fiction
that's ever been made 100
i got reminded of that after remembering
everything that's
everything that berserk did it's like if
the [ __ ] doom guy
had like a wife and family and he just
went home sometimes
you get reminded and you get reminded
like oh [ __ ] cause when you're willing
to guys like why am i killing these yeah
yeah what is my puppet
because i don't know why someone
compared it on twitter and i thought
that would be i guess so but then i
read because i'm like yeah but
it is kind of like you do forget because
sometimes it's like you're reading it
you're like this is like so doom-esque
where he's just
literally just beheading horses yeah
yeah yeah and then you're like oh it's
just like dude but then it's like really
sad you're like this isn't like
this it's literally that meme where the
girls were like i can't believe you
didn't cry during titanic
do boys even have feelings and then like
this there's just the boys
crying over the theme which was
literally what i was doing
was playing and i was just like crying
in bed just like oh my god
yeah i don't know it's just yeah like
every time i reread it
it's just because you know every time a
new volume came out because there was so
much time in between like the later
volumes
i was like well [ __ ] i i guess i have to
read it from scratch again and so i
would keep reading it from scratch over
and over again and it's just one of
those shows where i'm just like
how does this not get like stale yeah
because i probably re i probably read it
like the first 30 volumes probably like
a good like maybe 10 20 times
yeah i'm just like how does this keep
just getting better like how do i keep
finding new things in this
i mean you guys know me i don't [ __ ]
re-watch anything and yeah refuse to
re-watch but
i even just re-reading the first uh the
what was the first art called the
god of nature golden age that just
rereading that again i'm like holy [ __ ]
this was so good
yeah like even though i've seen this i
i've read it earlier like i tried to
read it again ages ago for some reason
now i'm like
sometimes when i'm bored i just like go
to the eclipse arc and just look at the
art yeah
this is like this [ __ ] wait how can one
person think of this
yeah i know this is insane and dude was
like 15
as well when you like first came up with
the concept of berserk yeah did you see
like did you see the manga he made
before berserk when he was actually 15.
he was like 15 or 16.
it's better than most modern manga
this is not the art skill of a 15 year
old exactly exactly and like he paired
that's
talent and he he just kept improving on
it to the point where
literally i don't know there's only if
like a few people in the world who i
think can even match
you know the talent that he put into the
panels that he did i mean i saw this
like really interesting interview
uh with him like after you know his
death was announced um
where like apparently one of the big
reasons as to why he was on hiatus was
because he got so
infatuated with detail that it would
literally get to the point where he
would zoom in
and like actually edit every [ __ ]
pixel
yeah oh my god honestly and like and
sounds like a prisoner
yeah and and he kept and he kept you
know getting like on hiatus over and
over again and his you know editors
would be like
you can't even see this detail on paper
yeah so like just stop and he was just
like nope
i have to get this right i have to get
this perfect honestly like some of the
panels he's done
belongs in a museum you know yeah
because like i cuz
the reason for that is because i just
remembered like that night when i went
back i just like
went to look at some of the panels and i
just remember staring at them for such a
long time
because you know when you're reading a
story sometimes you know you're you
wanna you wanna
you wanna see what happens next so you
don't read it you don't appreciate the
arts um at the moment when you first
read it
but i went back to look at some of the
panels and i just the amount of
work and the amount of detail and the
amount of vision that was put into
these panels were [ __ ] amazing and i
did not appreciate it
fully the first time even though i could
like tell these were amazing i didn't
take the time to fully appreciate
how [ __ ] amazing these some of these
panels are because they are
incredible and they they you know they
they are just basically the same as any
other painting or any other art i
really wanna you know see if they have
like a berserk art book
of some kind because i would [ __ ]
purchase that in a heartbeat dude
i i i i can imagine that they'll
probably end up doing something soon
yeah celebrate the legacy right i hope
they do
like open up an exhibit or something
yeah because that would be
absolutely amazing because if there's
one you know one manga that deserves
an exhibit that deserves that artwork to
be plastered on the wall
it's yeah [ __ ] berserk kind of sad to
see that a lot of people were just like
well what's going to happen to the story
and it's like
those aren't fans of bizarre yeah it's
frustrating that like
when i saw the announcement on twitter
showing people being like does this mean
it's not going to finish it's like it's
like yes no [ __ ] that's
to me it's just so it's like how about
you just give them a chance to like
grieve before you ask these questions
if anything i'm kind of your answer's
probably going to be no because there
were a lot of people as well being like
oh but you know they could probably just
get like mirror's assistance to finish
it
and like no no no no i would rather it
just be where it is
yeah just end it i'm i'm fine with it
being an unfinished masterpiece yeah you
know that's
that's fine that's fine for me yeah it's
berserk was it realistically ever going
to finish do you think
i don't know i mean i don't think i
don't think like not
not a single one of like the you know
the kings yeah were like killed i think
only one of them was i think one of them
was yeah yeah
so that was a long there was a long long
way to go yeah we
we were so early in the story and the
pace that the story
was progressing i doubt it would have
finished in our lifetime or you know
i i think it was always going to be
unfinished but i think
berserk's already achieved enough that
he doesn't need to be finished it was
like what i said when we talked about
the last time we spoke of reading manga
where i just get to
i often get to a point when reading
margaret i'm like i'm satisfied
i i genuinely it would be cool if this
ends nicely
yeah but i've read up to a point where i
feel like i'm happy with what i've been
given
yeah and i feel like berserk has
definitely done that yeah
there's been plenty of moments in
berserk that have felt like a resolution
moment yeah like a big resolution moment
even though not every plot detail was
resolved even though not
every loose end was tied up i feel like
it's resolved enough in my heart
to make it like impact me this much
already you know and i think the berserk
you know the journey of guts is already
amazing enough as it is
and some journeys you know some some
journeys don't need to come to an end
on paper you know that's it's i've seen
enough of the journey where
i'm satisfied it's yeah it's it's just
knowing that he's
he's out there somewhere still yeah
looking for the end right exactly
the biggest [ __ ] sword fat [ __ ]
sword